What have we hear?
Those were the first words out of the mouth
of Gene Stockwell on
May 3rd, 1964 in a small
building over on Boulevard in front of about 130 people.
In fact, these are right here. You'll see it on the screen.
These are the notes from which he
preached on that first Sunday.
What have we, here was the title of that sermon on that day,
the Henderson Hills mission officially began, which later,
uh, a next year became Henderson Hills Baptist Church.
See, in the 1950s
and sixties, uh, a small group
of people at First Baptist Church of Edmonds saw the need
for a new church in a growing neighborhood about four miles
south of their current location.
And that neighborhood was called Henderson Hills.
And there were many men
and many women in First Baptist Church over the years
that sacrificed and gave so that this mission could begin.
In fact, they not only gave, they went, many of them went
to this new church to say, we want to plug in to a place
that's going to reach a new group of people
that we're not reaching right now.
But that what have we here that Stockwell was asking
that day, that question was, was nothing to do
with the building or with the plot of land
that they were on, that the church had perched.
It was none of that that Henderson had donated.
It was nothing but what God said.
This was, what have we here?
What does God say this place is? What does God say we are?
And what he said in that sermon was that their mission,
what he says, God says about them was
their mission was make disciples.
Their body needed to be unified to do that.
That God's word was their guard and their leader,
and that the Holy Spirit was their power.
Now, that's a sermon I could preach again right now, huh?
Like that's something we could just pull
it out and go again.
But with that as our foundation, I want us to turn
to one Corinthians three today
for just a sh a few short moments.
This passage in one Corinthians three has been our theme
as we've planned and implemented this weekend.
Just what this says, our, our guide as our heartbeat.
Because obviously we want to honor those
to whom honor is due,
those whom God has used, that's biblical.
But we also need to have the right perspective
that Paul really has about himself
and about others, that even as we honor, even
as we celebrate, as we have our favorites and things,
and we don't divide over those things,
that was the whole theme of this
Chapter. Look at what
he wrote, the Apostle Paul to this church,
one Corinthians three, starting in verse five,
what we can learn from this watch.
He says, what then is Apollos?
What is Paul servants through whom you believed
as the Lord assigned to each?
Let's just pause there for a second what he's saying
to these people who had camped out
on who they were following.
He says, it's not about the person preaching
or the person leading or the person
discipling or the person, whatever.
It's not about them. He says, all
of us are merely servants.
In fact, I went back, Dennis
and watched your retirement sermon and
and what you say in there is that,
that we are mere conduits.
That that's the goal is that you don't remember the pipe
through which the water comes, right?
You remember the water. So that's the goal, is
that we're merely servants what Paul says here now.
Now we've been given a task.
We have been assigned something to do.
That's the first couple words of verse six.
Notice I planted Apollos watered.
So they had been given tasks to do,
and as I'll say next week, were to do that faithfully.
But look at what's next. Continue that verse.
I planted Apollo watered, but God gave the growth.
God gave the growth. It's the whole point of this weekend,
the whole point of our church for 60 years is
that it's God's work.
It's not us. It's not how we can do it.
It's God's faithfulness to his people. He causes the growth.
It's not about any of us. It's about him.
In fact, that's what he says in verse seven here.
So neither he who plants nor he who waters is anything
but only God who gives the growth.
It's the only God can take the credit for the last 60 years
of Henderson Hills and,
and whatever he gives us in the future.
Only God can take the credit for that.
We plant, we water, we do these things,
but only God causes the growth.
And then in verse eight, he adds this.
He who plants and he who waters are one,
and each will receive his wages according to his labor.
What that means, he's saying, you fall a Paul Apollos or
or anybody else in the world,
like we're all on the same team, this gospel team,
this Jesus team, we're all working for the same purpose.
We're all together. We're not against one another in this.
Now we have different tasks.
We've been assigned to different parts of the field,
maybe even varying levels of harvest based on which part
of the field or what time of the year we are working.
And the Lord rewards those faithfully,
but we're all working for the same goal.
We're all one. He says, in fact, verse nine,
we are God's fellow workers.
Like what a privilege it is.
In Luke 10, he, he says, Jesus says,
the harvest is plentiful, but the laborers are few.
Ask the Lord of the harvest
to send out more laborers into his field.
Here, Paul says, we are God's fellow workers.
We are those laborers in his harvest field.
I mean, just think the Lord of the harvest has allowed us,
given us the privilege to work with him
in his power for his harvest.
What a gift. It's his grace to us.
Whether you're on the stage preaching, singing,
leading kids, or whether you are serving behind the scenes
and in merciful ways, caring, that's all harvest work.
I planted Apollos water, but God costs the growth.
But then notice in verse nine,
he shifts to a different metaphor.
This is verse nine, all the way
and beyond He, he says, you are God's field, God's building.
He shifts to this building idea. In fact, he describes it.
Look at verses 10 through 15,
our role in this building process.
According to the grace of God given to me like a skilled
master builder,
I laid a foundation in someone else's building upon it.
Let each one take care how he builds upon it.
For no one can lay a foundation other than
that which is laid, which is Jesus Christ.
Now, if anyone builds on the foundation with gold, silver,
precious stones, wood, hay, straw,
each one's work will become manifest,
become clear for the day.
We'll disclose it because it will be revealed by fire.
The fire will test what sort of work each one has done.
If the work that anyone has built on the foundation
survives, he'll receive a reward.
If anyone's work is burned up, he will suffer loss.
Though he himself will be saved, but only as through fire.
Now, when we look back the last 60 years,
we're not saying Henderson Hills is perfect.
We can all probably recount times where we've built
with wood, hay, straw, right?
The stuff that, yeah, like the three little pigs, the stuff
that gets blown away real fast,
but the things that last He says the gold,
silver, precious stones, the things we're building with,
that's what God has used
to make Henderson Hills the way it is today.
Because back 60 years ago this, this church was started
with the proper foundation,
which Paul said was Christ the gospel, the life, death,
and resurrection of Jesus in the place, place of sinners.
That's the foundation. And it always has been.
The foundation and forever will be the foundation.
But then what was built on over the years,
as Paul said here in one Corinthians three over the years
were stones laid on that foundation of sound doctrine,
of generous giving, of faithful serving,
of sacrificial mission.
And you're building this building
of God in a way on the foundation.
You're building the stones of love for the poor
and the outcast and the orphans and those who are forgotten
and the widows and,
and you're building the stone of holding fast to the Lord
through deep tragedy and loss over the 60 years.
See, that's the kind of stuff that lasts.
That's the kind of stuff that God builds his church with
because it's what he says matters.
Not all the other stuff, not the the silly wood, hay, straw.
He's like, no, these are the things my word says.
These are the things that matter,
and you build with stones of those things.
That's what he blesses.
And so here's the question in front of us today, church,
as we build on this gospel foundation,
how will we build, we've heard what he's done.
How will we now build?
What stones will we put on that foundation?
Because look at verses 16
and 17, do you not know that you, that's plural.
He's talking to the whole, not just you as an individual.
You together are God's temple
and that God's spirit dwells in you.
If anyone destroys God's temple, God will destroy him.
For God's temple is holy, and you are that temple.
We, the church is the temple of God.
The spirit of God dwells within us.
And so we as the temple are building upon the stones
of those who've gone before us.
The stones have been built,
and now we're building on top of those.
We're adding to it,
and those 60 years from now are gonna be adding on top
of those stones as we go.
And so will we be faithful with our part.
Take care how you're building.
He says, how are we gonna be faithful?
They've been faithful for us.
Will we be faithful for those coming behind us?
Will we exemplify this counterculture community
so transformed by the gospel that we're different,
different in the way that we serve wholeheartedly different,
in the way that we prioritize God's word
above every other voice different in in the way
that we sacrifice
to plant other churches like First Baptist Church planted us
60 years ago, different in
how we are anchored by these cherished doctrines
of the church for thousands of years, yet also willing
to adapt our methods to reach the next generations
different in how we love our neighbors so much
that they are compelled to love God through us.
Yet we can't forget this church.
We can't do any of that
unless God gives the growth.
That's why he should get the glory for this.
That's why this is about him.
Not any person, not any group, not any era,
not any program, none of that.
Psalm 1 45, unless the Lord builds the house,
the laborers build in vain.
May that be our prayer
and our theme, our posture for the next 60 years as well.